The Joe Rogan Experience and to feel
that energy of of people wanting you to
succeed wanting you to do good you know
people that were there for for the ride
back at the Ice House you know 20 some
odd years ago look at all those people
yeah that is insane that's insane
it was it was a beautiful moment I was
choked up in the first 30 seconds
walking out there because they just kept
cheering like like you know and then I
said we did it and it was just it was
over after that so it was a big
emotional you know show for me
um on Netflix it was an hour and almost
two hours but the actual night I was on
stage for over three wow and they could
not get me off that stage because then I
broke up broke out a bottle of tequila
and then I turned it into a big
Quinceaneras what I did at the end and
uh I got fined by Dodger Stadium for
going over the time if you run the light
of the club it's yeah all right come on
maybe you mess up how much do they find
you well you don't have to say it was
over a hundred oh Jesus Christ Dodger
still come on guys stop being [__] is
that like operating costs like what is
that well you got to figure all the
costs that go into like you know the uh
the union the staff I mean there's so
many people that weren't worth it though
yes I do it all over again it was the
greatest night of my life and so happy
to pay the fine that's amazing that's
when I saw Bill Burr do Fenway Park a
similar sort of situation you know like
holy [__] and to do it in your hometown
yeah that's the best part I think it's
always harder to get love at home you
know that's why you go out on the road
and you do your thing and I think that
getting that love at home like I never
got to perform at a comedy club at home
until I became successful on the road I
didn't get the laugh factories of the
comedy stores or the improvs until I
went out and did that doesn't make sense
though why why would that be were you
hanging around you got to figure 20 some
odd years ago
um you know maybe they had a Latino
night you know you had to really know
somebody somebody had to really vouch
for you or you you just
it was weird most of my shows were at
bars so what year did you start I
started in 97 97. so most of those years
you're hopping around doing bars
one-nighters and stuff like that oh
so-and-so has a room so-and-so has a
room you know ideas took me to a lot of
those places oh yeah Joey Diaz would
tell you come on [__] you want
to go to the real place he would take
you to some Chinese restaurant in the
middle of nowhere it's run by Mexican
people it was amazing Joey you want to
say basketball would spend his weekends
he would go to all these [__] crazy
shows but he had a philosophy behind him
he was like you know I want to go
everywhere I want to go everywhere I
want to get in front of these [__]
Momos I want to go down to the east side
and rock those [__] he was just
like he wanted to do all kinds of
different shows like just to like feel
it out you know and I think he's right
they're like those dingy bar shows
there's something about those shows that
teach it's a little extra mumbling yeah
the cool part was is that I was used to
performing in places like that before I
actually got an audience that was
willing to just be quiet and listen yes
so I felt like oh wow that was hard you
know because you have to come out the
gate swinging to get people in a bar
people that are focused on the game
focused on trying to hook up having a
drink trying to wait you know waiting
for somebody there's all kinds of
different things happening and so the
fact that you know to be able to go out
there and get their attention yeah you
know that that that was like a uh like
it was school yeah it was school it is
cool it's a school that no one is going
to give you a lesson plan you got to
kind of do it all yourself and you got
to learn from the other people that are
doing it like Joey but it's like I did
the same thing in Boston we mostly we
got Road gigs because those are the ones
that you know they would pay you to
drive for two hours into some you know
40 minutes in front of a bunch of crazy
people and you were excited to do it oh
my God yeah it was amazing just the fact
that you were making money doing comedy
was amazing and you're learning how to
do it you're learning how to do it the
hard way in restaurants and bars and
pubs and just yeah weird little outdoor
venues and there was no on social media
back then no YouTube no Tick Tock video
clips no nothing that you could post you
just had to go out and but honestly
that's great because that that gave you
this chance to first of all know you
really wanted it because if you were
really going to grind it out every night
going all these weird shitty places for
no money for years for years you're not
making any money you got to be committed
to that because a lot of people they got
half one foot in one foot out they have
one good set and they're like yeah maybe
I'll give comedy a try but guys like you
and guys like me we're out there every
[__] night every night I knew that
with time money would come as long as I
I stuck it out you know I was in a very
cushed position when I started doing
stand-up so it was it was a little you
know challenging to say goodbye to
security you know I had I had a great
gig selling cell phones I was making
about 5k a month you know and in 1997
you know working in sales making that I
had never had insurance I had uh you
know a nice little PPO plan couldn't you
work there during the day I did for how
long I did I lasted about a year because
I found out that I couldn't just do my
job and then go do shows at night and
then go home you couldn't go home you
had to stay out we had to wind up at a
Denny's you had to wind up at some
freaking taco shop or whatever at two
three o'clock in the morning talking to
other Comics because that was the only
other way you were going to find out
about another show you couldn't send a
tweet you couldn't send a text because
you didn't have that as an option you
had to talk to people right so-and-so
has a room oh really what's a okay give
me that number and you had to learn the
right numbers and save numbers and
information and learn how to follow up
hey what do you think about you know and
then yeah yeah can you vouch for me that
meant a lot back then someone calling on
your behalf hey so-and-so's got a tight
10. yeah it's huge you know that's huge
so staying out late at night uh coming
home at four or five in the morning and
then having to be up at seven to go do
my nine to five it fortunately I was
young and I was able to hang for about a
year and then I just couldn't I was
falling asleep sleep at work and I got
caught
I got caught
you know I was working inside of a
little uh kiosk selling cell phones and
one time I just kind of let me do some
inventory here on the floor and then I
guess I was snoring and somebody oh my
God oh my God
that's a beautiful story though yeah
that's an American dream and I thought
that because I had done a couple of um
television shows and I saw the money
that I could make doing stand-up at that
time I said oh well and you start doing
the math the the delusional math well if
I get one of these a month and I do this
and this and this I don't need this much
to pay my rent this much to pay my car
note I'll be I'm gonna be fine and I
quit my day job and I got
um evicted from my apartment because I
ran out of money so fast
um they came after my car the repo guy
was looking for the car I got evicted I
went to go sleep on my uh sister's couch
it was it was one of those